6 23
monday morning what's driving you crazy
well metro police point out a painful
truth
fatal hit-and-run auto pedestrian
crashes
are solvable crimes that's what metro
lieutenant greg munson told our
christian continent
saying investigators start with a
specific theory
on all of our hit and runs that we've
had and we've investigated we've solved
none of those people left that day to
kill somebody that wasn't their intent
that'd be a different crime
munson says drivers in these incidents
can only help themselves by stepping
forward
people have to be held accountable for
their mistakes but don't make them worse
for yourself
and even if those folks don't turn
themselves in their own behavior often
gives them away
somebody knows who did it somebody knows
a friend a brother says somebody knows
if somebody comes to you and tells you
that hey i just hit somebody i think
you should absolutely step up and say
you need to go and turn yourself in you
need to call the police right now
if the community is willing to help us
with this we can
we could close all these every one of
these unsolved hit runs we have right
now
somebody knows about it somebody knows
about it pretty strong stuff so the road
to closure and unsolved cases starts
with somebody doing the right thing
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there's something
driving you crazy email me traffic eight
at eight newsnow dot com